the metronome the method
the crowds we are talking only Mexico
City six million people get named to
make a ruse and make most of them are
poor people no tengo cuenta de lancret
this is cash economy no reason kappa j
cena corona you know me gustaría
napolitana van pack for Rosa and your
daughter sandy being part of Mexico
City's massive cash day-to-day economy
means joining the millions of people who
commute into the city center through
Mexico City's Metro one of the largest
in the world and recently the immense
cash filled Mexico City has started to
look very interesting to one financial
company in particular it is MasterCard
global vision to go after cash cash is
actually our biggest competitor in Latin
America because it's like 85% of the
transactions that people make at least
in Latin America are cash based the
estimated 22 million people living
within the Greater Mexico City area
about 55% of them live in the informal
economy and don't have a bank account
even for those who do it's still a city
that runs on cash line form at ATMs on
payday so you can withdraw cash to pay
your bills and using credit cards to buy
everyday things like for instance in one
in Mexico City's busy public markets is
only slowly catching on for owners a lot
of Thomas efectivo rocky anorexia have a
few basic feel a cobra okay thank you la
mayoría no no vent apportion so en
efectivo
Adrian poor sense
so MasterCard is working with the
government to increase the amount of
vendors accepting credit cards but they
also want to just increase the amount of
people who have cards in the first place
where one is more masa card cards in the
market that's what we want we're going
to bring more cards into the market
using the transportation as an excuse
remember those six million daily Metro
riders they all pay for their metro
rides with one method the whole market I
will give to someone for pedals is for
London clinical people Mexico cities
Metro is one of the most subsidized in
the world it only costs five pistols
about 25 cents but you can only pay in
cash you can either buy a paper ticket
or a refillable card but there are no
automatic vending machines you have to
line up at a staff ticket booth and fill
up your MetroCard in person in cash
there are long lines just to reload the
transit card so MasterCard approach to
Mexico City for a partnership saying
look how about instead we just give
everyone master cards that are recharged
automatically from your bank accounts
it would mean no more lines for the
metro this sounds like a great deal la
ciudad de risco no para un centavo a
master car por el proyecto es un ganar
ganar s on win-win when it launches
it'll be just like Apple pay or other
top and go services you just tap into
the metro with your debit card from
MasterCard and the money comes right out
of your bank account but in order to tap
in you need a bank account to start with
and a lot of regular Metro writers like
Roseanne or daughter sandy simply don't
have one which is also why this whole
MasterCard initiative sounds like a
win-win for the Secretary of Economic
Development who's trying to bring
millions of people out of the informal
economy and into a place where the
government can see them we need to make
it easier for people to be included and
people to see the benefits
and of the risks because for many people
the risks are becoming part of the
formal sector where you have to pay
taxes the city signed on to the deal in
May 2017 the first varieties of debit
cards should arrive in November
MasterCard hasn't provided a lot of
details about how these cards will be
issued but they're hoping that
eventually like perhaps by mid 2018
everyone from a fruit vendor to a
government payroll employee might have
some version of a metro naval debit card
and that they pay them for everyday
purchases - what we're getting a return
for the more the card is used if it's
using the restaurant I live pharmacy at
the supermarket we that's our business
model we make money out of platform
section MasterCard is paying to upgrade
Mexico City metro because they want
people to use the card outside the Metro
the transaction fees that MasterCard
would collect in bulk would definitely
pay off they succeeded with this in
Colombia with Bogut --is Express bus
system where MasterCard introduced a
similar debit card targeted towards
people whose paychecks are directly
deposited into their bank account
there's a perfect product for payrolls
because money comes in every 15 days so
nobody needs to think about reloading
the product because money will be there
but this highlights the larger divide in
Mexico and in Latin America more broadly
between economic classes and the
catch-22 of going cashes in this digital
economy to data financial ad the only
way to have financial identity is to
have a bank account that's the
fundamental problem with cash to get a
bank account though you need to have
enough cash in the first place to even
convince a bank of giving you a debit
card and for Rosa that's just not so
easy to do Ave explodin el trabajo con
vino de Nunez a viernes Y it is not you
have to understand how they implement
sector is the restriction for the visa
program is the income level of the
people though we are very unequal
country the Mexican minimum wage today
is four dollars a day it is ridiculous
by all terms
[Music]
so as MasterCard targets cash in Mexico
the reality is that because so many
people live on so little of it a
cashless economy is still a ways away
even avec de veau envelope weighed
imaginary oh well no lo lo le Moschino
en efectivo lo pues no hassle meant a
ineffective oh no pero la gente Aleta
busca la manera de traer main ordinarily
efectivo possible creo que sería
question ah damas de tiempo lo veo muy
Lozano muy muy futuro many personal
turkey sample a dead
most modern cities in the world are
moving for that and Mexico City is not a
video stem
you